hi everyone welcome to my endgame
lecture series on Tuesdays today I want
to focus on an important topic in the
ending not the Berlin ending and it's
King position in the end game and in the
end games we're going to look at today
the main theme is one side has a better
King than the other and usually in the
opening when you move your King up like
most of our chess club members do then
you don't do very well but in the
endgame
now you're looking good now what I did
last time was I started with an ending
of a good player then I looked at my end
games and then finish with an ending of
a good player me however I'm doing the
opposite this time we're going to look
at my game and then look at good games
and finish with my game this was a game
I played before everybody was born the
only people on earth were me and my
opponent so the end gameplay wasn't very
good however when the end game finished
I talked to pal Benko about it my pal
Benko now most of you think Benko is a
good end game player because he has a
column on the end game so you have been
thusly tricked very good ok so I had
this position in the world open I'm
going to say 1985-1986 I'm probably
right it's probably one of those years
and I was white and I fought a long time
and I played the move King to d5 ok
which is ridiculous and my idea was
he'll make a random move which he did
and I'll play e6 and he'll take and I'll
go here and so forth that was my plan ok
but after King to d5 I think actually he
played here and I played six he played
the only move that draws who can find it
Jim Volker rook f5 check and now
irrespective of where my King goes I
can't win
because my King needs to be on d5 so if
I go here for example he pens my pawn
and I guess I could try to lose I mean
II seven losses so that's pretty bad
okay and this is the way the game
finished we agreed to a draw here okay
and then we didn't have computers back
then that played chess anyway so I
analyzed the position by myself and I
found a forced win for white and uh
actually about thirteen years later I
had the bad side of a very similar
position at my opponent could have won
by playing the same ID I'll show you
here and he didn't find it after the
game I showed him and he was shocked
anyway after this game and I figured out
the way to win I saw pal Benko they're
walking around and I showed him this
position and I said what do you think
about it White's applied he said that's
a draw and then I showed him the winning
movie he said oh yeah now it's a win so
it changed his mind immediately when
shown the right move so White's a
playing win who can figure it out who me
what we'd already figured it out but I
figured it out so long ago I forgot it
so such a one so the move is very
counterintuitive it's the last move you
would think of that's why I didn't think
of it that was good reason now the
normal way to play is to play like f7
and King e7 and then you don't win
because here you have no threat
if you ever queen for example white just
white just black just takes everything
and I can't win although I could get the
opposition with King in - sure done this
okay but actually you don't want to
Queen your F pawn you want to Queen
you're a pawn because when you Queen
your F pawn blacks King as close to the
e pawn when you clean when you clean
when you clean your F pawn it's really
clean okay
and my comment will tell you when the
chess club closes we clean all those
pieces especially me
that's about all I do so if you can
Queen this pawn somehow the black King
is going to have a tough time getting
all the way
the f1 also if you queen your F pawn
you're a pawn is on the fifth rank if
you Queen your EU pawn your f pawns on
the sixth rank also if you queen your
eep on the black rook isn't behind your
upon so Queen your e pawns really good
because black will have to play rook e1
to the stop it so having said all that
I've given away the first to move I'm
sure you all know you are the only one
who knows King f7 right that's the
winning move now white wins easily black
has to play rook e1 to prevent the
queening and we queen and very easy when
of course and most of you can mate with
a queen not to Thursday people but most
of you can okay so King f7 would win
it's sort of funny to put your king in
front of your advanced past pawn but it
actually saves a tempo because if you
Queen your F pawn by playing the move
King e7 and then FA Queen that's one
King move if you queen you're a pawn
it's also one king move and the
difference is black has to play rook e1
he doesn't actually move his work if you
Queen your F pawn so King f7 wins
handily luckily we have computer engines
now that can back me up and is is this
winning and instead of saying plus 20
plus 38 just have backed up so I was
like alright so King f7 the only winning
move although I didn't find it we're
okay
one of the most famous rook and pawn
endings since Julian was asking about
rook and pawn ending is this one kappa
blanka tartakower and this was played in
the famous new york 1924 tournament is
that your favourite tournament might
come ER or do you prefer 27 as that was
a tough question they're both good terms
now if black plays rook takes c3 check
white will play king g4 and King takes
f5 and white has two connected passed
pawns that's pretty good so charter
college just took the bishop and this
position material is equal in black is
threatening rook takes c3 check after
which he would be upon ahead and the
white a pawn
funds and deep ones are very weak now
since this is the most famous route
component ever I'm sure you're all
familiar with it can I help you are you
familiar with it yeah
and Jim Volker is like what No No maybe
vaguely familiar okay good enough now if
you remember the theme of our lecture
and I did say it a few minutes ago so
you know you're probably playing video
games at home right now but there was
King position if black were to play rook
takes c3 check here I don't think white
would have a good King position you see
what I'm saying I think the King would
go back it'll be terrible okay
if white wants to move his King up the
board other than cheating with Kiki for
King g4 how could he actually do it
without cheating you King to g3
and after takes King to h4 or as I would
say put it in H now it's very difficult
to protect the f4 pawn and when I say
very difficult I mean impossible so
black played rook f3 and even though it
was 1924 he was looking forward to
playing pacman rook f4 rib d4 rook a 4
and white has no pawns left but that's
ok what only needs one pawn now Tyler
tower was not familiar with the Blitz
game between Ben Feingold and Mike comer
played earlier today where comers King
and pawn were up there it looked like he
was going to checkmate me he was shocked
that he didn't and capablanca obviously
was familiar with that and played the
move g5 and then King GG v g6 King g5
King f6 with a mating attack just like
comer could have done and King to have
six threatening rook h8 mate so even
though black is up to pawns I slightly
prefer White's King slightly also my g6
pawn is a little bit better than your
pawns also the white rook is going to
take all the black pawns and the white
king could take the f5 one now most of
you in the audience would play King
takes f5 that's actually the last thing
you want to do and if you were thinking
that
home you should be ashamed that's not
the only thing you should be ashamed
about - I know who you are so at your
king at five White's King has no shelter
okay and cap a blanket knew a lot about
shelter because his favorite group was
the Rolling Stones Kappa Blanc was all
over that
so King to have six it's impossible for
black to check from behind because the F
five point is in the way and if you were
watching my comers lecture earlier and
I'm sure you were there was a game where
Selden shrimpo with a white pawn on h6
play King h7 and the white pawn was
blocking Mario's attack very similar
kappa blanka learned almost all of his
endgame knowledge from Mario
almost all of it okay now White's
threatening Roque shape mate and these
guys were grandmasters so King g8 Rick
g7 check and excellent move most people
would play work take c7 but actually
it's very difficult for black to make a
move here if King h8 it's hard to get
out of the meeting net so obviously he
played it anyway if King f8 and we play
rook takes pawn we're still threading
all these checkmates King h8 I wouldn't
do that okay now I would resign if I was
black and I guess if you don't resign
you play rook e8 okay good yeah
now material is equal but now black has
the pawn hanging and black sting is in
the corner just terrible the game ended
quickly and whites up two pawns and
white was down two pawns about six moves
ago what a turnaround okay and for some
reason there's no reasoning going on
here what why isn't black reasoning so
what's happening what world am I in okay
and now he resigned okay so very
suspicious non resignation there for a
few moves but you can see the most
important thing was King position now my
dad was very impressed with that game he
liked the way white sacrificed all his
fonts because King could move up blacks
King was terrible and black had to give
a lot of pawns away to avoid checkmate
blacks rook was worse blacks King was
worse and he made it look like it was a
very easy
when one of Kappa Blanc is most famous
endgames now this is bob maddox most
famous ending although this point was
argued earlier today by my son Spencer
he's like this is his most famous game
so you know you can you can pick and
choose now this game reminds me a lot of
a game I discussed last week where a
Lexus Shirov played them with bishop h3
put it in H and and won brilliantly this
is very similar now most of you if you
were playing this position would agree
to a draw because bishop opposite caller
is no legal way to win the H pawn can
Queen the G pawn can't Quincy Ponca
queen your only pass pawn is the B pond
and White has two pieces stopping that
so this looks like it's completely drawn
in fact if you put it on your engine the
engine also thinks it's a draw but you
know the engine isn't quite essential is
about Vinik Bob Malik was pretty good
and I have a lot of funny about
inventing stories one of them was in the
early 60s the Soviet Union was picking
the Olympic team although at that time
Olympic team picks you because it was no
Soviet Russia and all the top players
were sitting around they decided the One
World Champion super Grandmaster who
wouldn't make the team was Botvinnik
they said he's no good and somebody's
like well he's the world champion ok but
they had a lot of world champions or
future or former world champions they
had Smee Slav they had Kara's they had
Bronstein they had tall they had Spassky
they're like a bob maddox no good
eventually they put Bob Vinick on board
one instead of not letting him on the
team and he won the gold medal so maybe
he was ok I forgot Petrosian also pretty
good team ok reasonable team anyway yeah
and tall even wrote about it he's like
you know we thought Bob and it was no
good but he's pretty good ok so Bob
Lennox black in this position it looks
like a draw he's playing Alexander Kotov
I actually have a funny Kotov story and
it's a really good time killer so
let's use it Kotov was driving in Russia
okay so dangerous and he was driving
with the feed a president this was in
the 80s
Florencia compo mayonnaise your favorite
feed a president and of course the cops
pulled them over because you know Russia
and codes I was driving and he was like
nah because it was the feed a president
and gets his driver's license goes back
to the cop car comes back he says he
says no no no ticket for you you're
Alexander Kotov and coats I was like oh
you're not giving me a ticket because
I'm the famous chess grandmaster
Alexander Kotov and he's like what he's
like no I'm not giving you a ticket
because my name is also Kotov so so he
thought he was a great chess player but
he said the same name as the cop okay so
cotons white against Botvinnik
and Bishop e7 attacking the pawn Bishop
f5 daring him to take the pawn do you
think white should capture this pawn
what do you think I see head shaking I
hear a lot of noise rattling around
going on okay the answer is fries I mean
the answer is no because then you'd lose
your age pawn and then black would put
it in H black needs that H pawn to Queen
so white just plays Bishop f6 and says
none o you can trick me okay King f3 now
we're going to attack the e pawn and try
to Queen our D pawn how are we going to
win the e pawn we're going to move this
and hope for this King goes and takes it
then we'll take the e pawn but code
clubs not falling for that either
my comers like ridiculous that's not
going to happen you have a question sir
okay you play Bishop e7 Bishop to g4 is
the same and he pushes the pawn and he
goes King c3 and he's like okay take my
e pawn I don't care and Bob Manik plays
Bishop e6 an amazing move obviously if
King takes b3 d for Shaq and we take
this and this pawn is looking pretty
strong this pawn is looking pretty weak
okay so codes I didn't fall for that
code soft play Bishop c5 and the players
agreed to a draw
next game no that's not what happened
okay now Bob Vinick played the greatest
company should ever seen in an end game
totally confusing my comer
he played g5 just like Mike would do now
obviously if we take with H pawn then
this H pawn is pretty strong and when I
say pretty strong that's an
understatement
that will soon be a queen so obviously
took with F pawn now if you're going to
play g5 sacking upon what's your follow
up Mike d4 second your other point as
expected now the points is if black
let's go back if black ever tries to
take this pawn white will play Bishop e7
if what black ever tries to take this
pawn he'll play Bishop c5 so whichever
pawn you attack I defend it but by
playing g5 now Bishop e7 no longer
defends the H pawn illegal you can't
jump over your pawn and by playing the
move d4 check he makes it difficult for
white to recapture for example King
takes pawn is risky as Julian will tell
you based on his Bishop and pawn
anything earlier b2 so the King can do
it so he took with the pawn and now King
g3 and we're going to take the H blonde
and we're going to have to pass pawns on
opposite sides of the board these to
pass pawns are blocked by a bishop the
blight King can't come and help because
b2 is winning if you remember the theme
of this lecture it's been like five or
ten minutes it's it's King activity
White's King is basically sitting
babysitting the b3 pawn blacks Kings all
over the place and whites pawns can't
Queen because the bishop stops them both
blacks H pawn can Queen because blacks
king is going to escort it along
Bishop a3 coach off has the right idea
his Bishop will stop the pawn and my
king can do stuff I have a king to cakes
cakes h4 and he's like mean there's
pawns on both sides of the board what do
I do
well the bishop can't stop both pawns
you just push them both the bishop can't
go so we need the bishop to stop one and
the King to stop the other so you play
King after me and my comers like wait a
minute why don't you just play d5 yeah
Bishop d6 check King takes h4 fine let's
let's let's analyze let's see analyze
King takes h4 which one what do you want
to do right I'm gonna put my King on
well now put my King on g2 and do this
and I'll take with the king then you're
like wait that's not good for me yeah
the only way that's not a good ending
yeah yeah ok so Koltsov tried to stop
the b-pawn with his king with his bishop
and stopped the age form with his king
he tried to anyway ok and now here he
resigned and in fact if you know a lot
of obviously bishop endings and i'm sure
you do this actually reminds me of the
final position of nakamura carlson from
the tom memorial 2011 you can look that
up at home they're not going to remember
it a minute but you can write it down or
something
replay the video ok in an end game naka
also had to stop pons on both sides and
you your king can't move both directions
so obviously the White King is going to
babysit this pawn and blacks going to
come do this and unfortunately for white
the bishop is controlling the queening
square making the Bishop and pawn ending
very easy to win
so after Bishop g5 check Kotov resigned
but g5 was an amazing move I'm sure
Julian agrees more amazing than Bishop
age 3 4
sure of he's like now yeah I was kidding
but yeah long as you agree but the point
of g5 is to win this h4 pawn making it
impossible for the bishop to defend
because White's pawn is on g5 and if g5
doesn't win which it does you still play
it because otherwise you can't do
anything so you get a chance to win you
get past funds everywhere and opposite
colored bishop endings if you have
passed pawns you want them as far as
possible maybe one on this board and one
on the next board okay we call that
Julian or Sarah one chess or something I
don't know lots of chess boards going on
here but okay in this instance Age pawn
and B pawn that's pretty far apart
that's about as far apart as the
Portland's main in Oregon right okay
Julian knows that kind of stuff although
I was told Julian's moving to Florida
which I didn't agree with but I was told
that you know people who don't know
anything okay
now the next game is my game with Bobby
Fischer oh wait a minute that's not me
it's my dad's game with Fischer from
1963 which I'm sure you all memorize
before class now you'll notice there's
an equal number of pawns and it looks
like all ten pawns are isolated but
they're not it just looks like they are
okay and the reason why has the
advantage is white as a better King
White's kings on the fourth ranked
blacks King is on the third rank another
reason white has an advantage is this h6
pawn that's very close to promoting and
it's on a dark square so I don't think
black is going to capture it less you
cheat
okay Fischer played Bishop to a two and
said it's your move and blacks like I
don't want to move I like where my
position is there's actually more than
one zooms along this game but here black
has everything on the right square you
don't want to move this pawn because
then White's going to go take it you
don't want to move this pawn because
White's going to take it you don't want
to move this long as it's illegal Julian
is like I don't see what the problem is
Julian yeah
now this should be one you can't play
we're getting ready to get to that yet I
suggested but it's bad Bob Bishop c4 to
b5 okay
so he played f5 they traded and now as
Julian was about to point out before I
interrupted him
Bishop b1 the recommendation of my comer
fails to e3 and now we're threatening
the bishop and we're threatening e 2 and
E 1 so black would win and that's what
happened Bobby Fischer resigned wait
that didn't happen okay so Fischer saw
that by the way if black can play III
this should be one wins immediately so
you got a C III otherwise resigns after
he three white resigns chess is tough
okay so he played Bishop to b3 and
unfortunately black has to move black
doesn't want to move blacks positions
perfect okay but he loses bishop now
after Bishop EA Bishop g6 is risky
so black didn't do that white would take
the bishop and Queen his H pawn if the
bishop moves somewhere else the bishop
on f5 that is your pawn is hanging if
you play a four I take it if you do
anything you lose so black played the
obvious move c5 check I take on pissant
and that's defended so he played the
obvious move King e7 and when the bishop
moves away then King back to D six and
we're all set but Fischer didn't move
his bishop shocking the audience
what did Fischer do if he didn't move
his Bishop he's only got one other move
my comer King e5 now the King and pawn
ending is incredibly winning for Wyatt
because the e4 pawn is going away so my
dad moved his bishop and now Fischer
played the most brilliant move of the
game although not really my comer is
like totally obvious
Julian Bishop to g6 and that aged pawn
is pretty strong we can't take the
bishop because white gets a queen but
now white just takes everything okay and
then resigns
so that was a nice ending the Fisher one
basically because his King was much
better than blacks King and having said
that this was the famous chess
tournament where Fisher stayed up all
night and then fell asleep against
biscaia what blunder did busy ir baked
in that game
Jim Volker ah my comer knows he woke him
up yeah I was what a blunder all he did
was not wake him up and he was all set
but he woke Fischer up and then Fischer
beat him yeah
so that tournament was played in Bay
City Michigan everybody's favorite
tournament venue all right now we'll get
on to the game
Yates Marshall a very suspicious game
but the players you know between 1910
and 1930 didn't always play the end game
perfectly they usually did but not
always okay now here why does the Queen
up so normally if you're one of the best
players in the world and you're up a
queen you will win normally but okay
this wasn't his day okay and black is in
check so black escape check now if you
put this on your engine at home or if
you're one of our more intelligent
viewers here white can announce me
there's maiden nine there's maid in ten
there's Maine and 11 and there's several
moves that do it the best move is Queen
c2 pinning the b-pawn in attacking the
a4 pawn and it's just made it a few
moves
what black really can't do anything but
Yeats thought he had it all figured out
okay but he missed something so now if
he was in time trouble or if even chess
clocks existed I don't think he had any
increment or time delay I don't think so
not in 1929 okay maybe he just got a
drink because it was 29 who knows anyway
white play the incredible blunder King
to c4 okay the biggest blunder of all
time in this game anyway and he thought
if black Queen which black did do that
he would take said Queen and he would
play King beef
for stopping the a pond and the f2 pawn
is unstoppable
okay little did Yeats know that in 1923
rady made a chest problem very similar
to this one which was a white supply and
draw a puzzle you all know okay and
while Marshall either knew the puzzle or
he figured it out but this is black to
play and draw now what black wants to do
he wants to stop white from queening
that would be a good idea and he wants
to Queen his own pawn that's also a good
idea if you're taking notes cleaning
your own pawn is a good idea what move
can black make which simultaneously
moves towards both pawns
Julian somehow well that's not the right
notation yeah
King b2 right now if it was blacks turn
to move black would win a3 a2 a1
probably Yates only looks at King 2 C 2
then F 4 resigns that was only variation
he saw but after King beat soo he
probably realized his indolence was
inefficacious
probably right even though the Simpsons
hadn't come out yet he probably
predicted it now after King take say for
the only move it doesn't lose king c3 no
problem and we stopped the pawn although
he still tried to Queen here okay okay
then he's like alright yeah and now the
game would normally continue this and if
you're a smart aleck you go here okay
yeah and then then you promote to like a
bishop then you go here you can't claim
a draw the game is automatically ending
in a draw no more moves are allowed or
my comer puts the hammer down as the as
the TD so King B choose a pretty cool
move because it draws in a threatens to
win so white has to be on the ball here
and play King takes a four he loses
that's funny you're a queen up and you
play King C for triple questionmark
chess face has no annotation for triple
question mark I can't get it to
it's oh so yeah but every move wins and
I think Yates knew that yeah I thought
Yates
I think Yates knew every move won and he
just didn't see King beat so he thought
this was the easiest okay but it was not
only not the easiest it was wrong okay
that's okay we can make fun of him for
centuries so okay now that game was
pretty bad but it was no trash unlike
this game
Lasker tar ash okay now this game was a
double Bishop ending and they just
traded all the bishops okay and tarush
was doing a Mike Hummer he was like this
pawn isn't going to Queen but these
pawns are going to queen so he was like
I'm going to be Lasker and tarush and
Lasker didn't like each other
unlike players of today we all love each
other okay but back then they didn't
like each other okay in you know Tyra
shows like I'm going to beat this world
champion what a pot sir I got him
crushed so tom has played a five and he
was like I'm going to get a queen but
you're not going to get a queen okay
however if you saw the last position
which I showed two minutes ago you can
actually figure out how to draw this
with white also if you were the world
chess champion Emanuel asked you could
also figure it out okay Lasker not so
bad
Lasker was the see the second good
player in chess more fee than Lasker
than everybody else was pretty good okay
but between Morphy and Lasker a lot of
suspicious characters blunder blunder
blunder blunder was like the Knights
tournament okay and but Lasker was
pretty good so even these complicated
endings he could figure out the only way
to draw now if white does nothing black
will make a queen I guarantee it
let's do some Mike hummer analysis let's
do nothing okay then a four okay and
then we'll do nothing and now you can
see either pawn move wins let's go here
I don't know and then we make a queen
so blacks going to push his pawns and
make a queen I guarantee it so white has
to do something about that but as you
can see these moves are illegal I can't
get my king over there and even if I
could play King f7 I still can't get my
king over there this King is stopping
everything so lasker plays the only
logical moves to get counter play Mike
comer h4 put it in H now if it was
White's turn to move
why would play h5 and win so he didn't
like that so he played King to g4 if you
remember the last puzzle you will know
what white did in this position white
moved his King towards both pawns
obviously overlooked by tarush you King
to g6 now White's threatening h5 which
would win if white plays King F six
black wouldn't take this pawn black
would start the queening process and
black would actually push his C pawn
because the white king can't catch the a
pawn
ah even though the King is in the square
that pawn is not really helping white
very much can't take your own pawn okay
so Thomas thought he was probably going
to win but Lasker played the brilliant
King to g6 now White's threatening h5
which Queens the pawn so he took and now
the white king is just close enough to
stop the pawns and draw a greed even
here every almost everybody can draw
almost if you've been to the Chess Club
as much as I have and you don't say
everybody but King g6 very similar very
nice idea I like it okay now the last
one is my endgame because we start with
mine and finish with mine we finish on a
low note unlike George Costanza again I
just went to a Festivus party so I'm
against Costanza now this position
material is equal but my rook is better
than his rook and his bishop on g2 has
no future
okay and actually a
lied to several universities and they
said no they said you're terrible you
can't go anywhere
you got nothing okay now my opponent
played King to e1 kicking my rook out
but I've been kicked out of better
places okay and I'm like I don't want to
get kicked off the seventh ranked I'm
going here and he's like not on how you
you you got to go okay now I made a
controversial move okay I gave my rook
away confusing Mike comer because he
doesn't see how I could give my rook
away it's like how'd you give your rook
away of course I could trade but I
didn't want to draw because then I
wouldn't win if you're taking notes
write that down when you draw you don't
win okay well if you don't want to trade
if you trade rooks I don't think you're
going to win I think it's going to be a
draw so I played the obvious move Julian
there's an obvious move that's not rook
takes rook I'm serious
you can find it a three I didn't see a
three then he would take my rook and go
in my pawn right I don't like to add
that I don't have that pot anymore it's
the most obvious move on the board
my comer there's only one move this
Knight rook takes rook I guarantee it
rook c2 okay now if his Knight moves
away I don't know where it moves away
yeah well you will yeah
now the knight can't really move because
that a2 is hanging and also I don't see
a place for the knights of 90 ones
terrible 94 I just when the HP pawn and
I win so my opponent played a very
sneaky move confusing Mike comer yes
King to d1 and my rook only has one safe
square here and then you plant king
daeso and I have no safe squares what's
that just like who yeah I've done a ruck
so I resigned exactly yeah and I've
applied on e6 so it's very similar to
the French all right now some of you may
have been to my previous endgame lecture
is you may have even watched at home and
you probably commented something like
bring back Aviv okay anyway in my
endgame lectures I talked about two
things very very common move your king
up the board and advance your past
spawns and have lots of past spawns if
you don't Queen upon it's a very hard to
win an endgame mating with a lone knight
not easy mating with a bishop not easy
promoting upon to a queen and winning
priceless
okay now I am going to lose my rook but
I'm going to take a lot of pawns so I
start taking them and I have a minor
piece and two pawns for a ruck now some
people like rooks you're allowed your
own opinion and I like crooks as well
however I don't see what white rook is
going to do usually your rooks on the
seventh rank and it's great that rich is
on b1 doesn't do anything also when you
have extra pawns which could happen then
you want to have a majority of pawns you
don't want to have three pawns two two
and three pawns to two you're not going
to Queen those pawns
you want three pawns to zero or three
pawns to one or four pawns to one and
your pawns are overwhelming and this is
exactly what black has black is even on
the Kings side but has three pawns on
the Queen side now any Grandmaster would
want to have black here because black
has good winning chances probably blacks
not winning but blacks going to try to
win and White's going to try to stop all
those pawns computer says it's about
equal but that's because it can somehow
stop the pawns but humans can okay so
here come the pawns let's go with the
pawns hooray for pawns okay yay pawns
more pawns okay and he's trying to push
his pawns but he's just kidding okay my
pawns are the ones that are yeah those
are some good pawns
okay and this was quite funny
I select bonds by the way okay and this
is one of the funniest things that ever
happened in my chest career ever not the
funniest but one of the funniest
this position I was waiting the last six
or seven was for my opponent to resign
and when this endgame started
I'm slightly better but then I pushed my
pawns up and he did nothing meantime
trouble but obviously White's position
is silly he's King and Bishop er here
Mike King walked up the board his works
on the seventh but it can't attack
anything and I've won upon and now I'm
getting several Queens so every move I
thought he would resign but he was
making moves okay that's his choice and
this position my opponent went to make a
move and I thought he was putting his
hand up to resign his hand like this and
I was expecting resignation so when he
put his hand out I put my hand over the
board and he looked at me and you went
yeah and he shook my hand he was like
yeah I resign I sort of enticed his
resignation she's like that's better
than what I was going to make right if
you put this on an engine it says I'm up
six yeah so I I was when he looked at me
and like stuff with his hand I was like
oh he's going to make him move darn but
then he's like yeah okay I resign sure
yeah that's what it is here yeah yeah
that's the least amount of fun you can
have because you're King Bishop and rook
are all terrible
I would probably play b3 and then I
would move my king and Knights up and
man it's not fun for Wyatt I mean it's
fun for black you could do that I would
agree with that rook to d2 like I like
moving my king up because that's what
the lectures about so and then I'm going
to play Knight to c4 and man it's it's
tough it's rough I tells you well after
Knight c4 I think I have a lot of
options yeah yeah he's good yeah at the
higher level as you resign here to lower
levels white wins half the time yeah
yeah I'm going to leave my pawns here so
you suffer I'm never going to move them
you're going to look at them ago ah
why are the guys pawns there if I was
black I would play Knight c4 and my King
would come up here even here that's how
strong blacks position is yeah yeah if
you put us on a chess edge and it says
blacks up like ten sort of like the
equivalent of a queen because why can't
do anything yeah but see here's the
thing you guys wait for your opponents
to resign that's why you're not
grandmasters you have to like insist are
you resigned
yeah I've actually resigned from my
opponents and blit scams they usually
agree when they're down nine or ten
pieces they're like all right right now
here you don't necessarily have to
resign but he moved his hand in such a
way where I thought he was resigning so
he can he tricked me
but the way he shrugged his shoulders
and shook my hand that's that was that
was one of the greatest moments of my
chest career I really like that and this
was I'd only worked with the Chess Club
here for a couple of months when this
game was being played and this is a
funny tournament because I remember I
flew to Dallas and I played in a chess
tournament life looted eventually was
Lubbock but Dallas than Lubbock I played
a tournament in Lubbock and I finished
my game on the last round and then I
flew to Chicago and played the next day
I'd never done that before and I and I
came in second in first
terrible okay luckily the Chess Club was
pay me all the time so that's that's why
I think I did so well but yeah that was
a nice example of bad King no good the
King on see ones not a good King and
advance your past pawns and in this
instance the pawns and his terrible King
position not to mention is terrible
Bishop positions bishops actually
trapped terrible but as Bishop has to
stay here so I don't break through and
get a queen although that might have
saved him some trouble then you know you
could resign okay you prefer black yeah
okay
so what did you learn about the ending
hopefully nothing if you're playing me
but if you're playing other people move
your king up unlike his King on c1 he
moved it up it was up for me the King on
c1 that's not you know he should be
should be taking my pawns with his King
and with so many arrows and red squares
then you'll be green with envy
and it also looks like a Christmas tree
good timing
question yeah what you said what diet
and now for my two favorite words of
every class class dismissed
very good